conspiracy theory okay coined long
before JFK assassination go lower to
take a look at the article okay claim
the terms conspiracy theory were created
by CI agency following APS assessment
false recorded use of the phrase
conspiracy theory dates back to 1863 and
it was notably invoked reports following
the 1881 shooting then President James
Garfield more than 60 years before the
CIA was established an academic review
of the digital library found the term
conspiracy theorist has been published
at least in the last what what do you
say to some like this where they're
they're quick to jump on it to say CI
didn't come up with the conspiration
they're calling it a conspiracy theory
yeah conspiracy theory came from the CIA
go read the church and Pike documents
the church and Pike committee was the
most effective House and Senate
oversight of the U.S intelligence
agencies they received death threats
they were followed and intimidated they
came up with it so it's not like we
pulled it out of thin air the church and
Pike committee discovered not just the
heart attack gun which is a real thing
thing by the way they discovered a gun
that they could shoot somebody and make
it look like they had a heart attack
fake an autopsy but they discovered that
the Central Intelligence Agency via
operation Mockingbird a real thing used
the the term conspiracy theory and got
it into public opinion as a way to try
to discredit dissonant opinion it's in
the church and Pike uh documents so
people can read it for themselves the
church and Pike committee was what year
did it was it 70 something yeah if I'm
not saying 76 right
um yeah I mean it's all there the
thousands of pages of documents that
most Americans aren't even aware of
you'll learn more about your government
cointel I can never pronounce right
cointelpro operation Mockingbird
um there's five or six of these projects
that the intelligence agencies are
running that the pike committee
uncovered
in your opinion all these conspiracy
theory stuff what turned out to be the
biggest
non-conspiracy Theory Epstein's up there
and and what do you think is actually a
conspiracy theory that Americans like
hey sorry to break it too high versus
truth is about yeah I hear what you're
saying go ahead
um well I mean there's there's several I
mean one of the ones we lived under in
the last couple of years was that
somehow closing schools and getting kids
away from each other some are going to
stop the spread of the virus and if you
push back against it you're anti-science
and you're believing in conspiracy
theories right that's a really big one
um how about that the vaccine is safe
and effective and gonna stop
transmission I mean my mom got diagnosed
with covid today she had every booster
on the planet so I mean that was today
today I'm like how are you feeling
moment yeah out of nowhere I think that
I think there's a lot to the JFK
assassination I personally believe there
was more than one shooter I think
there's a lot of evidence to support
that we don't know that for a fact
because they keep on suppressing the
release of those documents
um I think that this idea that somehow
we got off a metallic-based current
currency just for good and Noble reasons
I think is insane just read the correct
the creature of Jekyll Island which is I
think one of the most Illuminating uh
books on currency Scott took his whole
team to Jekyll Island at one point yeah
we had a in the room where they came up
with the whole thing we had a meeting
there yeah so anyway but no I mean
there's there's several of them how
about this uh when we used to say that
there weren't weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq we were all called
conspiracy theorists turns out there
weren't
um they found some biological and
chemical agents but nothing near what
they told us it was right which was kind
of the core centerpiece of I think the
illegal mistake to invade Iraq one of
the worst mistakes in American history
what's on the flip side what do you mean
meaning like what actually probably is a
conspiracy theory oh um man you you guys
did we land on the Moon is the earth
round yes we do we do have a spherical
rounder yes yes that that that is
correct you could prove it
um and you could prove it mathematically
you could prove it flying in a plane you
could prove you could prove it when you
see a boat that all of a sudden just
discipline goes the Horizon that's how
you know you live on a spherical round
those are the dragons over the edge yeah
that's right that's why we have to carve
the uh the goddess in the front of our
boat to protect
usually landed on the moon yeah I do I
think we landed on the moon and the
reason being is that look it's I I don't
have any I'm gonna get so much hate mail
for this and that's fine but generally
that one seemed too big to cover up that
there would take too many people and too
many actors and too many fake stories
and I think there was a really good
MythBusters that actually went against
the kind of flag waving part of it again
I don't what about a 911 I do not think
it was an inside job I think our
government probably had had
aforementioned notice yeah I think our
government probably probably knew that 9
11 was going to happen they had ignored
intelligence reports there's too much to
suggest that we allowed the hijackers
into our country and we did nothing to
stop it so you do think it was the
inside that's not an inside job
necessarily an inside job would say that
the government was actively planning
explosives and wanted it to happen I
think that there was probably a turn of
the head on for whatever reason you
could figure it out we probably will one
day
um of some sort of domestic attack that
the ISL the Islamic fundamentalists were
plotting or planning but I think it goes
too far to say that our government was
planning explosives in the World Trade
Center I don't see any evidence so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]